might be two other rooms open to us
until three-thirty so maybe our gifts
with stick around ok I want to introduce
our speakers Christie's behind the
podium is a new faculty member of the
NHS over at Hunter she teaches courses
on and tell a teaching reading writing
and materials development she brings to
brings to us for classroom experience
teaching EAP after work with university
writing centers including appear online
Writing Center in Japan and your editor
is professor of t-cell of five min 57
and her area of interest and it's pretty
simply teaching and learning a second
language literacy and English language
learners she's offering or co-author
write articles and books including
reading for meetings may have used it
and rating connections she's getting
workshop to train yes L efl teachers for
more than 30 years in US Japan Korea
Vietnam in Mexico Kristin de Janeiro as
a director of ESL in the English
department at Pace University her
research interests include I was in
writing writing assessment and
generation 1.5 a second language
research has appearing language testing
and the journal basic reading and our
own show she ought to teach here is it
easier that's right and our own Shelley
salzman understood we all know Shelley
but we're just going to highlight it
think that she's done for right of why
we invited Raquel as you know she's been
at the ALP for 20-some years has taught
levels 1 to 10 including the four credit
college composition for international
students and she's the chief editor of
the way of you writing guide often the
third reader of the ALP sa examinations
as we all know and proficient crypt
previously an official scorer I just
read here right on the tweet which is
the test written English the right a
component of the total yes going and the
appeal which is the Advanced Placement
and international english language test
okay so there's your video we're going
to start with the steam
and what I want you to get from it and
deserve the title disclaimer for any
about that teachers that it's how i'm
going to complex p so all the next class
this is a little bit simpler but three
talks about how there's so many
variables and they're all we have of
course the teacher and student but then
he has a teacher response and that's
just the beginning and you have things
like what focus on the common structure
institutional pragmatic festers are the
students taking the course for credit
what kind of support do writers have of
the institution the teachers orientation
what does a teacher bleed when your
student characters different teacher
characteristics and she talks about
sometimes personal dynamics and
backgrounds also affect how we respond
with writing the other thing that I've
learned to show you all this pain is
just take a moment to read a little bit
about these comments for more
perspective his name was actually bingo
and bingo that means listed for this
huge directed
you know it's like an introduction
necessary the seventh lon that keeper
he's living a little profession do you
know what I mean asked a lot of
questions like this it shows the rise of
tension and this burger was a huge bingo
moment because made me realize how
important it is to list it from the
brighter what kind of feedback they like
and basically I'm trying to focus on
today is what happens when we take a
student requests seriously so before
that I was thinking about my own
experience the writing teacher now we're
love it goes attachment so what did you
do why did what happens if being
aggressive of something more like this
please check how's my grammar or was I
can fix it what happens one of you if
it's either your writing center tutor
which I have been or when you're doing
peer feedback in the classroom with
these other kinds of questions you hear
your writers asking each other and you
know that they are way too broad and
maybe not extremely the doctor so what
I'm going to do next is tell you what I
think or some underlying questions about
student questions I think as teachers
were trying to see how can our writers
improve your fluency and accuracy and
how is very well made self-regulate we
want them to persevere with the
difficult process of writing
the river for language we want them to
be able to adapt what happens when they
leave the English Institute and they
don't have awesome teachers who are very
patient and accepting a particular where
they're coming from and how can we
develop their skills so that they have a
network of critical friends I really
like this critical friends because I
feel like that has a few meetings ones
who is a friend that you're going to
turn to Wystan did prepare as much as
you should and is this the friend that
is also a critical reader do they give
effective feedback so these are the
underlying things I think teachers are
interested and development and are very
much related so I mean I'm also posing
questions for ever break but again what
support you writers need to a specific
man both dr. questions and how can we
manage feedback
get back to students and our feet after
ourselves and colleagues so this is
where I started with some advice savage
book treatment of error my data thurs me
when I first started keeping up and
slaying at the answer and this was my
Bible I literally my first writing class
full healthy participation in appendix
and my students and monitoring I will
give them feedback with codes and I
would have a mark what kind of errors
were most treatments and the hospital
corrections and I even wouldn't like to
a little tally you know write some
comments and I probably can't imagine
that there were more issues and that
were targeted and this was a little bit
so personal another exact feedback that
they might have been expecting um but
they were very diligent and this teacher
must know something how they did goodbye
but then I start to think about issues
of readiness and burn around Tommy
literature I started asking
during class discussions really I give
them something to correct and I would
ask them what would you do with it where
do your ideas come from and what are the
different ways of giving feedback what
do you think are the intent behind doing
something like folds with intent
information or what does it mean when
your teacher doesn't give you the answer
and just circles what do you think the
teacher for your friend or colleague
what do you think that they're hoping
you get a free breath and you know where
the advantages and disadvantages and it
seems to invasive but i actually just
hold them and said what method do you
prefer and why have you ever tried to
play everyone's an i tried bringing down
the different kinds of into explanations
that they would understand
and I started to do kind of gimmicky
things like this obviously I was
desperate this is circa I think 1499 at
the park and basically what i was trying
to do here was I thought I can have them
ask better questions if I teach them
money questions and then we compare them
okay what did what did you teach your
say and once you use it so I have have
my students attach this to their to
their writings and this was like one
that we're raising for argumentative
writing and so this these here are what
the students said and then I would also
give you chapter read some comments
about what they were
so it's told them what my assessment was
told them how they measure it out to
what I thought I think all those methods
get you somewhere but it's not that full
picture of goldstein's very cute you
know how plex sister so I realized I
need to do something else oh you see
that this means of even drawing this
house yeah really got into I there at
that time you know I would've thought
this was publishable and this goal but
then I read I need to broaden my
activities it wasn't just that event the
paper as a teacher born so start writing
feedback activities broadening and so I
would have students the right classroom
started looking very different form
integrated approach i'm short girl so
we're into to date and then we would use
newspapers to find on hot topics if they
were interested in we made research to
counter argue and i start your cloud
using discussion boards to have them
prepare for their four bits and what i
liked about this was that every someone
that was always writing the favor
so at the end I would make them the
debate was over a clown and make a
switch side provide argument in the
Oxford time so I sports we got to go
back look at what their classmates
sensor and from this I also started
noticing right now all feedback on ski
when I started noticing that my students
without being prompted to sign bingo
we're using different colors to talk
about the Ragman favorite book
instructor and I really liked it oh this
is very clever and then I also added an
element of anonymity so one day were
writing of just given a number and his
PA means purified
then I started asking myself questions
about what we were feedback event do
what kind of data which is specific to
writing for female
describe but I wanted to kind of tell
you some of things that I was thinking
about so I was thinking about the
hedging that you might do when you give
advice devil's advocate well you did
mitigate this aspect but I think you
might need to work on making connections
between that and making a good article
that would say well this is a complex
issues well it's your point here and I
started to feel like what also was
needed was taking some of this time
because I wanted them to right outside
of the classroom and so as Carol mention
that also done work
writing centers but it started in the
classroom and can stay as long as you
keep certain things
anonymity and fostering
so I started thinking about this is the
writer they make a health across and so
depending on the level it might be that
they are it's a very broad question them
and they put up that or give them
scaffolds do you have a topic sentence
the standard kinds of questions
depending on your classroom
and i'm just showing that things as a
process of first reader second reader
that i've gone from where penalty
and they will then email co-instructor
advice to you writer you're answering a
question and then also focusing on this
a typical feedback on people so next I'd
like to actually show you some of that
language you can start being here
going back to the original pointless I
want to go how to develop the writers
better captions copyright wenn second
language writers were giving your
feedback Anna's father didn't ask it to
your question they started using some
interesting language
you
so that you can see that putting someone
in the situation where they are eating
to answer a colleague or peer implicitly
it was teaching what I I could have done
I had told them a million times so you
see that they're getting okay your
question was to broaden it was quite
burdensome for us because this was
online they need to start using language
to be interactive and still they don't
want shoot down there friend so they're
trying you're basically teaching this is
a restaurant
and I started looking at these kind of
questions so what do you want and so
next you see I use can hide on this
model of dis works and he breaks it down
to interactive and interaction which
works perfectly
the language that you need to feel close
to your leader show that you want them
to be involved
so from thinking about students
questions making them to insist an
activity like this I started seeing very
rich language
and I compared to two classmates steps
for students who were not doing this
kind of activity and I found that those
who were dissertation were asking better
questions are specific questions they
use a greater variety of that many
disappears although they weren't being a
specific talk hey this is not a
discourse they're writing more time and
they became more self regulated and I'll
explain more me started giving me a
window into my teaching I could tell
from
teacher and a nice thing about having
okay so these guys nice will be shining
differences so you can see again these
questions I gave them both groups the
same
you can see again yeah we're joined by
members that essay topic was is better
if you remember we were here to go like
to a full these samples are come to town
so the writer pol writers so you all of
your line parts of the more the various
if i compare that to someone who didn't
experience they do a kind of maybe more
distant interaction with her running
they got the formal style the formal
style lankan enhance different
organizational skills but there's not
that connection that interaction is not
what
and I started learning from my students
things that they didn't understand so my
favorite class me when asked about
transitions they kind of said what is
that and then they looks to teacher
resources like this one or ones online
that basically give you a list right if
you want to add something can you these
five so I had them start making their
own materials because if they don't
understand that the person I giving
advice to and we see things like this a
lot that text heavy they were using
there are more pages to this but instead
of using a makeup test about the person
informed
they were
diary of wimpy kid and eva the extra
fare they were looking for the published
writers but they were using textbooks
for sure that to these like things that
may be teachers might think oh that's
they're going to think it's more like a
testing center but they review things
like okay get it a stopwatch now
remember what kind of community things
but I have to stay there cheers were
like you can see that a writer would not
feel dr. bum that all benchmarks
everywhere every
um so what that was my experience there
so to be back show me more things that I
hadn't thought about from my students I
thought about materials and I thought
about implicit activities that would
actually improve i ordered manages
course it's gotten me really hooked into
giving my students as many chances as
possible to use different needs to give
you back on feedback so some things I'm
looking at now so your cat changes so
I'm just using track changes here and
again this is a little bit of a
different stuff this is the question
black reaction computers
Ryder a strong Bob and in green is the
piers stab at answering and then I'm
giving the dis rider feedback on their
to be back with my fact changes but then
I'm also adding skype and what I'm
finding is that sly gave them just
asynchronous stuff like a traffic change
file that there are as you can guess
things never work that I was writing in
my comments that they didn't understand
and so now where I do is I wait for them
proper okay in this example my feedback
was the student just said remember the
full of practice makes perfect reading a
lot of jobs can help you but they also
have to prove me so you can see mistakes
and
continue to make the same things over
and over and so I'm rocking the river
here what was the East Pacific or were
mistakes that she made give one or two
before Matt
and here i'm waiting us they do that
also i'm not sure we check out the
speaker yet you can share the document
so we're both looking at the document
the same time this is something that I
couldn't have done in five years ago the
technology push it and here before I
showed you that I had surgery right
materials here during the skype chat
you're actually looking on
understand so it's just combining the
various things and seeing what I get so
just I'll do this again as our
underlying questions what does feedback
our feedback tell us about sweetie and
Christie house to yourself right here
and with my research I found that
students were spending more and more
time when outside the class are outside
of any duty that they were doing this
were writing section
they found that it was very when they
were making material
I can talk more about
about any are too um but I have a little
caveat my head I was two sided and I'm
going to ask you all to please look at
the side that has locks on it and not a
little bit back side and that's because
i'm going to give you a task to do with
the front side and later you look at the
back side where hopefully will baby come
to some agreement or some of the things
that
so I could pass these around here so
remember the box okay
are you
and then be taking nested a slightly
different direction from what Christine
talked about I'm looking a little bit at
she was looking at heavily at the
students and student involvement she was
talking about Prince writing and I'm
going to be looking at a different slice
of the pie I'm leaving the teacher and
baby and asking this question that says
are we i'll be doing a little bit of
background of how I'm situating this
within little all of those elements that
Christine talked about for error
correction and feedback and then I'll
tell a little bit about a study that
I've been working with and then we're
going to stop and look at the box on the
paper that you all have and then we're
going to come back together okay talking
a little bit about error correction so
I'm focusing on the whole concept of
so-called errors I just want to give a
really major caveat that says I
understand and I agree totally that
there are so many ways to give feedback
and errors is just one small slice of
the pie and so there are many men have
any points in the in the composition
process there are many different areas
and aspects that we give feedback on
including generating idea
all kinds of parts of it but I've chosen
care just focus on blood piece that says
if we all agree that giving feedback on
at least in some point in the
composition process giving some feedback
on choice of forum then what do we say
about it okay so I please don't get me
wrong that I'm saying this should be our
only focus or our main focus or anything
like that I'm just saying assuming that
at some point we do think that focus on
form is important what do we say about
that okay we know from SLA research that
corrective feedback has an effect on up
taking community of settings and that's
post days of oral language feedback and
there's you know way back crashing came
out with a heavy statements that said we
shouldn't be focusing on form except
when we have lots of time we have
prepared to monitor ourselves and I
think a lot of teachers especially k-12
teachers and so that's not all you
necessarily but through a big slice of
our colleagues have sort of went in the
direction that says focusing on form is
not so good such a good idea and then he
raised a lot of questions in our minds
however since then people sort of took
him up and said well let's look at this
let's invest
further and a lot of people have
actually and now we have a fairly
substantial body of research that says
corrective feedback police orly does
actually promote murder of aiken and and
students actually do get something from
that and do you improve their accuracy
not just fluency and you know doing
Williams long mr. Ranta and others list
goes that direction if we look at
writing there's been a similar sort of
argument about whether it's useful
whether it's helpful and I know probably
my later panelists will keep talking or
give us a little bit more on this you
know some people have said it's
effective in fact it might be harmful
some say it is effective and it even
promotes learning in other areas some
have said it's effective in the
classroom setting where which is where
most all of us operate and increasingly
though if we go back to do this really
wonderful book Ferris says there have
there are now there's not a body of
consistent findings that says students
are able to reduce their errors over
time with appropriate feedback build up
evidence let me say okay to support
probably what made us have intuited for
a long time okay at the same time one of
the reasons that people have has claimed
that feedback has not been so effective
is because teachers of us have not been
up to the job okay and in fact there's a
whole slew of research that says it's
really the quality of the feedback that
we've given it's been incomplete it's
been missing credit it's Iraq and it's
inaccurate okay and so that's pretty
daddy I think for us to hear and in fact
is a very well-known quote Vivian's an
old name a g'day t5 which gets quoted
and recorded where she says SLT writing
teachers mystery student texts are
inconsistent in their reactions make
arbitrary Corrections right
contradictory five minutes okay now she
goes on to makes another point which is
not quite pointless overwhelming they do
themselves as language teachers rather
than writing teachers need to have
primarily to service features of Friday
okay I'm not different in any way
suggesting we
only to surface features of right but at
the point at which we choose or students
request or we do focus on four features
in writing what can we say Ferris of the
one study that attempted empirically to
sort of look at this is Ferris 2000 they
found that teachers are correct eighty
ninety percent of the time it's a ten
percent of the time proximately teachers
actually doing the space in the errors
their identification papers okay so i
said i think this is very interesting
partly because i work in the preparation
of teachers and i'm very interested in
knowing is s and so I wanted to look at
this okay so my motivation was to look
at teachers knowledge of the earth the
relationships between syntax morphology
lexicon and how this plays our role in
our understanding our students errors in
our diagnosing our students needs right
that's our job not just to correct
errors on papers but to have some some
sense of what they need right and that
has to be based on our diagnosis of
their knee and then I my intent is to
fill begin to fill this research gap
where there's only one sort of empirical
study
that looks at all of that and looking
and also to begin to define what should
teachers what the teachers need to know
and be able to do and how well our
teachers able to use it ok so this
Ferris actually comes out and says a lot
of babies makers are in a curative
inconsistent their eyes yet no studies
that support this claim apparently and
one of the many kids that charge so so
that's where I to cover my questions our
teacher is able to identify treat their
students lexical tactical errors and I
chose to include lexical and grammatical
because they really blend with and I'll
get into that in much more detail
exactly what i mean by each of those and
i think that's
go further with that what knowledge do
teachers required in order to address
issues effectively appropriately so what
I did was as I gained assignment
basically to ESL teachers these are
teachers who come out of a master's in
TESOL program so this is sort of the
mind accepted standard for preparation
for himself and what do those people so
these are novice teachers now there was
some range in their level of experience
the point is not so much I got really
comparing groups of teachers or anything
like that I just sort of looking to find
what are their knowledge means what are
they able to do well and not so so most
of the one people
who were novice teachers so fresh out of
the master's program okay I asked them
to obtain a writing sample just like we
have examples for our students identify
three grammatical three lexical errors
in there it was their choice and whose
fry which ones I didn't give them the
right example I hadn't least ones that
their students do I asked them to
analyze them develop a treatment in
other words address each error develop
some kind of activity or instruction
practice business to that you feel will
remedy that error for that students so
that hopefully as you will not repeat
that error in the future to then meet
the informant again and explain the
error provide the treatment and then
write out a reflect on the process okay
so these are self reports they are
essays that each each confirm have had a
different student okay this was done on
purpose my intent was not to see could
they all do the same thing my intent was
to say in a real life in a real task so
just like all of us have our classes of
students we have to get them analyze it
and deal with it are we able to do those
things and also I was curious to see
what they chose what where they were
comfortable focusing on and that's part
of what I hope to find out so going
through the data of it through an IRB
institutional report review ordered
process my co-author be performing and I
determine categories of mental analysis
for these errors we were the two Raiders
we normed with each other and we
evaluated student responses separately
then we brought that back together and
any places where we disagreed we
negotiated we came up with in a sense we
came up with a neutral solution okay we
developed a list of what we identified
were successes and problem areas and
what are what our teachers were able to
do and we made a list of recommendations
just so you know we were working with
about 80 teachers and because they were
doing three lexical
medical that's six islands each we
eliminated a couple of items that were
problematic either misunderstood or they
occasionally one or two omitted one so
we ended up at the tumble 467 actual
errors that were corrected and so in our
analysis we looked at does the teacher
correctly identify error as grammatical
lexical or ambiguous because there's are
they able to do this and just so you
know they were taught this in that MA
program and they were basically this was
part of their training and so part of
the look at this was could they do it
then we looked at the specific nature of
the error because part part of what we
were interested in is one of the focus
on what are they comfortable is the
teachers analysis accurate is the
treatment appropriate and how might we
explain if they had an incorrect
identification
analysis we say here's our year our
results a total of four hundred
sixty-seven we get their ability to
identify errors now these are just raw
numbers here I didn't put percentages
here but you can see approximately seven
about seventy nine percent were able to
identify or wheat to Raiders
independently agreed was correct small
number here about 25 people were
partially correct in other words that
identified there's an error but they
didn't know what kind they're worse
however there were 50 spots possibly six
students teachers in that two errors in
that group that were incorrectly
identified just either not errors at all
and we were surprised
they identified something that just was
not wrong and this was my of course two
of our independent judgments when we
asked them to analyze it and then say
what's the error what's wrong you notice
our numbers go down and the incorrect so
what was for us seventy-nine percent
accuracy went to sixty-six percent
accuracy so about a third correct either
incorrect partially or completely when
we then ask them to address that error
provide some kind of instruction for it
okay and we judge appropriate pneus of
instruction in terms of does it fit the
error number one does it fit the level
of the writing in the essay because
obviously they need to make it fit we
didn't know all the students involved in
these essays but where do we did have
information on their writing we had all
the original writing samples and we want
to basically we judge that in terms of
we did it okay and what we found was
decreasing okay in other words even if
they could identify that there is an
error they didn't they knew less often
what it was and they were able to even
less often to address to to develop
instruction that fit the error okay so
what we learned was identified lexical
grammatical errors was complex it was
complex for us how much more rooted
would be for our teachers
and because we both have top courses in
most of our teachers seventy-nine
percent now this was it a little bit
lower than what ferus ferus about eighty
nine percent so we basically found four
out of five we're out of the stop we're
out of five teachers was four out of
five errors was that different correctly
okay but that means one out of five
twenty percent approximately wasn't one
out of five errors we felt was not
identified this is not even identified
correctly as an error okay two-thirds
about sixty six percent were able to
explain it correctly in other words they
were able to say what it was what's
wrong not just is it wrong but what's
wrong 55-57 percent of teachers provided
treatment so a little more than half
okay so what we found was identification
ability was greater or better than
analysis ability which was then even
better than okay and we found some
distant patterns of difficulty and what
they did and we then work to restructure
those which was our the first one up
there was our research question number
one the second one out here was re
situation okay we found that he came up
with some possible explanations for why
in a sense it might not work or why our
students our students our any teachers
were not maybe doing it okay so your
turn all right I'm going to ask you that
for this I think is to try to us to take
a look at some Arabists ourselves and
I've chosen pretty randomly got a secret
SI by an 18 year old Spanish speaker
okay and so I'll ask you to read or read
through the essay give you a couple
minutes and then answer the questions at
the bottom so first is can you identify
three lexical errors and we'll talk a
little bit about what that means but I'm
curious to see what you in terms of that
to memory cuz I haven't explained it
really very well yet three grammar
errors and then because we'd like to
take something
easy i think let's look at this person's
past tense music okay that's something
I'm sure all of you have taught at some
point and many do most teachers do at
some point so even something quite
simple like that let's look at see what
we can say okay so let me give you a
couple of minutes and then maybe I'll
ask you to him they just confer with
your next to you and see what you've
each founded if you agree with each
other
you
okay since I've been given the
five-minute morning I'm good at ask if
you could share out what you found and
I'm sure we'll keep looking and that's
fine and parking and you know addressing
if I find any lexical errors what would
you consider a lexical error now we take
care okay take care to modern modern
more than okay is that ok ok ok what
about misspellings what about this an
electrical error I'm sort of leading out
the spellings for right now is yes it
would probably be lexical but I think
it's a sort of a separate category in a
separate set of issues suitor for
logical form that's true yes so water
would be a case of probably phonological
so she I'll be permanent this is the
closest you could come to it and keep on
with modern instead of
okay so please okay to what should it be
a game okay right so the king we came
that's an easy confusion right so that's
nasty that could be what cuties in gotta
see they got a sick or gothic or became
sick right so but the came i think was
close to that ok any other lexical
errors you noticed danger what should I
need they Thank You the dangerous Oh a
word form okay needed a derivational
ending on there ok yeah that you hear in
the info that support of not recognizing
me as revealed meeting of here and home
okay so AB preposition that's a good
question that that's actually that's one
of the cases where the it's hard to tell
is that grammatical or lexical to hear
we don't say to hear right they came
here okay and here is one of those
special words where we don't say two
here and there you know here there
that way right anyway so is that lexical
with a grammatical delivered yes yes
that is glamouring that's right
graphical editor in order to fix to hear
can you explain this as a grammatical
pattern or as something that you need to
hear in every word okay dear their own
DOMA prepositions in front of them and
then certain other groups like like
school right groans audience hospital
jail last work oh okay help device or
how to talk to us it's Mexico and
grammatical because help the transition
as always they over that that's right so
that's what what Lewis calls of
categorization rules or syntactic
features of a lexical viral but
obviously there's
medical restrictions that's right
there's that's right and is there some
interference going on there probably ok
so there's in this case there's a
grammatical element of using a
particular okay so it's kind of in kind
of overlaps but in order to fix it what
do we have to think about probably that
word or just a small class of words that
operates that way but not all other
words do we can't teach it by with a
grammar rule ok so our medical errors
what kinds of her medical errors did you
Laurel nice another plural what negative
ok no something right the Jerry the
daring definitive choice of pentagons
was comma splice ok so sentence
structure run on comma splice amount of
issue ok
Let Go subject right okay there's a
typical spanish speakers error okay well
pronoun okay let's go to the past tense
what did you find about the past tense
is interesting my neath went to the
hospital they'll get mix that's so good
for you the right okay needed to go no
it doesn't walk on the bandstand Oh get
even past tense marker went on the
rubber guy okay and that's a tough one
that's good but that's part of the past
tense and but also part of the
complication right now we were
compliments okay so past tense what
would you say about this young writers
existence arm in being sisters
inconsistent okay what would you teach
this person in order to remedy her use
of past tense how would you teach what
would you design or what would you
explain or what would you design as an
activity or exercise before her
make them aware that stative verbs in
her at all is it is it only the first
kids
okay if you flip your paper over the
uses for you so I I've given you the
list of the ones that were correctly
used and the ones that were incorrectly
used so we can look at those are those
are those all stative verbs on the right
side have no take care of sleep work
with the night whereas opposed to Kate
was was studying toll
right after look okay so that might be
something interesting